it's great to welcome to the program
today Catherine eben who is an
investigative journalist and Fortune
magazine contributor as well as the
author of bottle of lies the inside
story of the generic drug boom Catherine
so great to talk to you today thank you
so much for having me on the show
so generic drugs is an issue that
relates to intellectual property it
relates to FDA regulation it relates to
the medical world I mean there's so many
different areas that are relevant to
talking about generic drugs but I guess
to begin with how far back does the
concept of a generic go well I mean it
really goes all the way back to probably
the 1920's 1930's but the idea that you
could you could basically be a company
that breaks down a brand-name drug and
tries to remake some version of it is a
very old concept in the sort of modern
generic drug world when we look at
generic alternatives to name-brand drugs
many people believe that it is down to
the finest level the exact same thing as
the brand name except without the brand
name it turns out that that that's not
always true and it's in fact often not
true in ways that are sort of concerning
and dangerous talk a little bit about
that right well it's actually almost
never true
so generics are not identical copies
they are versions of brand-name drugs
and the FDA recognizes that they're not
identical because they give a range that
the generic can fall into in terms of
the dissolution of the drug in the blood
so under the best of circumstances if
the generic is similar but not identical
they may have different active different
additional ingredients different time
release mechanism they're made in
different factories there
dissolved differently in the body but
where it really gets dangerous and what
I documented my book bottle of lies is
the ways in which generic drug
manufacturing plants many of which
operate overseas are actually committing
fraud and submitting fake data to get
approval from the FDA to sell drugs
right so there's sort of two layers to
this one is is there even the
expectation or belief that the generic
is in practical terms the same thing as
the name brand drug then separately for
that from that there's the question of
oversight and accuracy as to whether the
generic is even what it purports to be
and it seems as though both of these are
issues that are happening at the same
time right I mean the the idea of the
generic as a version and not an
identical copy is accepted and actually
acceptable and for many many drugs a
version is fine although there are some
drugs where really precise dosing is
required and those can be a problem but
the I think the greater risk for
American consumers is that the FDA is
not adequately policing these
manufacturing plants overseas and
essentially accepting the data that
these companies are submitting as
accurate when they are not and it's not
always I mean so we can there are a
number of criticisms of the FDA many of
which I've made on this program but is
this limitation in terms of the
standards that are being applied to
generics is this something that the FDA
is choosing not to do or is it something
that it is at least in some cases unable
to do well I think the two are somewhat
connected but basically the FDA is a
domestic agency that because of
globalization was suddenly required to
police manufacturing plants all over the
world and it essentially acknowledges
the difficulty of this because for u.s.
plants when they inspects
they just the inspectors arrive on an
unannounced and stay as long as is
needed but because of the complex
logistics of overseas inspections the
FDA
says that it's arriving to these plants
gives them weeks and sometimes months of
advance notice that they're coming
so my investigation reveals they will
send in the plants will send in data
fabrication teams to alter documents
invent documents back date documents and
these are all you know quality data
quality documents that speak to whether
the drug is bioequivalent whether it's
got impurities in it or not all kinds of
issues that are critical to have the
drug functions when we think about this
there might be people depending on their
health circumstances who here is talking
about this and they go to Advil versus
the CVS generic equivalent for example
but there are other people who may be in
situations where they are actually using
generic alternatives to very very
expensive name-brand drugs depending on
the the medical conditions that they may
have does your investigation suggest
that the same issues exist to the same
degree with both the advil generics and
the really expensive drugs for less
common conditions or is it more one
versus the other it's actually both so
just to give you an example in the book
I follow these cardiologists from the
Cleveland Clinic who realized that when
their patients were getting switched to
certain generics they were initially
stable and then they were no longer
stable and even they found that heart
transplant patients were suffering organ
rejection when they were switched to
certain Indian generics so there is a
that's generic drugs that were
manufactured in India so there's you
know life-threatening dangers here my
book focuses less on over-the-counter
drugs but you know what consumers should
know is that the drugstore brand say
Duane Reade CBS the drugstore chains are
contracting with the lowest-cost Indian
manufacturers to make those
over-the-counter drugs and those plants
are really audited and in
affected infrequently so there is a
quality issue there as well so I mean
having dug into this and investigated it
for the period of time that you did to
write the book is your takeaway that
there's just too much risk with any
generic and that patients should be
doing everything they can to get their
insurance to cover the name-brand
because I will talk about the sort of
practical limitations of that I mean is
it are you did you come away that
concerned where you would just want the
name-brand of any drug that you are
taking I would say two things about that
I came away extremely concerned and I
interviewed plenty of FDA investigators
who themselves would not take the drugs
made into plants that they were
inspecting but that said I also
recognize cost is a serious reality and
and it is for me as well so what I do is
I often ask my pharmacist to switch from
one generic which I don't trust to
another generic made by a different
company that I might trust more that so
it's you know it's it's knowable which
brands generics are more or less is is
trustworthy even the right word
it is a knowable thing now the problem
is do you have to be an investigative
journalist who's looked into this for
ten years to know it right on in order
to help consumers I have put information
on my website which is Kathryn eben comm
and so there is information about steps
that they can take to try to figure out
whether they're generic is trustworthy
or not and what the options are if they
determine that they want to switch you
know it is a bit of a maze I'm not gonna
be you know kind of sugarcoat that I
think what's really needed is
congressional action here to fix the
problems that I've exposed but in lieu
of that I think there are certain steps
that consumers can take there's also
something called an authorised generic
so that is a generic where the brand
company
has made a contract with a generic
company handed over its recipe and the
generic company is making the drug under
a contract so it's actually closer to
the brand and sometimes those authorized
generics are actually manufactured in
the very same plans as the brand-name
drug what what you know a lot of people
who have dealt with insurance companies
know is that depending on the coverage
that you have and depending on where you
get your insurance whether an individual
marketplace as a self-employed person or
through a work connected insurance plan
there are all sorts of complex rules
about what your insurance will or will
not cover when it comes to prescription
medications and doctors certainly have
the ability to put no substitution on
prescriptions which effectively tells
the pharmacy that a name-brand is what
should be provided but that does not
guarantee that health insurance is going
to cover the name-brand at the same
price that the generic would be covered
so this is I mean this is really
complicated stuff particularly for
people who require medications that are
extremely expensive absolutely this is
not simple and you're quite right that
even with the do not substitute there's
no guarantee that the insurance company
will cover a brand when a generic is
available can you talk a little bit
about I mean obviously there are a
number of different types of concerns
there there's straight-up safety
concerns right of side-effects that one
could experience experience adverse
reactions there's also the concern of
just a drug that in its generic version
is less potent or may not achieve the
same results as the name-brand how would
you sort of put percentages on those two
concerns and others that may exist as a
general rule when we talk about ways in
which the generics may be suboptimal
right so I don't know that I can offer
percentages what I can say is that even
if the generics are fine there is an
issue for what it are called narrow
therapeutic index drugs and so those are
drugs that require really precise dosing
and the doctors who prescribe those so
it's cardiologists like
trysts endocrinologists they are
familiar with this as a problem and they
have raised questions about whether the
FDA standards are narrow enough to make
to ensure that the generics are
clinically equivalent to the brand so
that's like in one basket of concerns
unfortunately with this other basket
there is really widespread fraud in the
overseas manufacturing plants that are
making the majority of our generics so
just as an example I feature in the book
an FDA investigator named Peter Baker
who became exceptionally good at finding
data fraud in these plants and over five
years he investigated 86 plants in India
and China and found some element of data
fraud or data deception in about
four-fifths of those plants so a
stunning number yeah it really is yeah
absolutely so I mean these are these are
plants that are doing everything from
using the brand-name drugs to run tests
and take that data and submit it to the
FDA as though it was their own data from
their own drugs so completely
supplanting the data inventing documents
and steaming them in rooms overnight to
make them look old you know completely
just discarding critical manufacturing
documents where FDA investigators have
dug them out of dumpsters when documents
are supposed to be retained so you know
these are really major lapses in what
are called good manufacturing practices
that these plants have to follow I mean
some plants have even wouldn't you have
a sterile manufacturing plant and that's
very serious they have to follow sort of
aseptic regulations um they have
literally invented their sterility data
they're supposed to test air water
surfaces to make sure they're free of
microbial contaminants and they've just
invented that data they're not really
running the tests so that's the kind of
things that are going on in these
planets absolutely absolutely stunning
make sure to check out Catherine's book
bottle of lies the inside story of the
generic drug boom we have been speaking
with the book's author Catherine eben
who is an investigative journalist and
Fortune magazine contributor Catherine
so great to talk to you about this great
to talk to you thank you so much